hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the stoic school
in ancient times tended to be rather
distrustful of
sexual desires and pleasures not that
there weren't legitimate circumstances
in which they could be enjoyed but there
are always a little bit dangerous and
we'll see why Epictetus himself didn't
actually have a party towards the end of
his life adopted a child and had a woman
who we might think of a sort of
housekeeper involved with him but it
doesn't appear that that he himself
indulged in any sort of sexual
relationships now the Stoics were not
actually that unusual in seeing
sexuality as something that we wanted to
pay attention to even the Epicureans who
want more faulted as being rather you
know driven by by pleasure
base pleasure at that if you read the
writings we're quite concerned about how
things could easily get out of hand and
what we see in timing about this in
relation to a sexual desire in general
or if we want to call it lost and then
in particular the problem of adultery he
also does try and here and there about
those who are perverse but he doesn't go
into any great detail about that he
tells us a bit more about why adultery
such a significant problem and we could
think of adultery and whatever we want
to call the perversions for him and
there's discussion about exactly what is
meant by that generally sort of
effeminate actions on the part of a man
and few other things as well pretty much
a lot of the things that we find the
Internet these days probably considered
perversions we can think of those as
sort of limit points of sexual desire or
lust when lust is indulged in it's
already very strong on its own we'll see
just how strong in a moment but when
it's indulged in and there aren't any
any limits placed upon it
no no you know barriers or controls we
could say then it's likely to lead to
what we call antisocial behavior and in
many respects not just antisocial but
anti-relationship behavior so what does
he have to say in the end karidian he
says one thing that's very interesting
and I've got this Greek word here
aphrodisiac so that means matters of
sexual designer matters of sexual
pleasure we get the word an aphrodisiac
from that and you know we think of
aphrodisiacs as things that are supposed
to arouse desire but for the Greeks this
word for D Xia meant the whole realm of
things that are involved in that so if
you're having sex with somebody that's
aphrodesia if you're sending them a lot
of letters that's offered easier right
and I suppose you know representations
they have you know various artistic
representations of people having sex
particularly on vases offer it easy so
given these in this the matters of
sexual relations and designer
he says preserve purity as much as
possible preserve a sense of you know
being clean is another way to translate
that and engage only in the waffle
pleasures so this means that you know
what counts as lawful pleasures well you
definitely don't want to be involved in
adultery because there were
laws against that in the ancient world
there is indeed there have been until
quite recently in many places and you
you also don't want to be doing anything
else that would go against the social
mores within the realm of sort of you
might say socially ratified sexual
pleasures it's not as if anything goes
whatsoever but you've got a lot more
freedom there so he also says that if
we're engaging in this this limited
behavior on our own part of keeping our
desires for sexual pleasures in check
which shouldn't be prudes about it we
shouldn't be getting in people's faces
and saying look at you and how you
behave should be carrying around signs
lustful people you know if other people
are behaving badly it's not really up to
us to correct them unless they fall
under our purview you know if they're
our child that maybe we want to say
something about it but if it's somebody
else's kid unless they're actually
getting involved with our kid it's
really none of our business and so he
thinks that you know it's important to
preserve a kind of reserve about these
these matters to you know to indulge
oneself would be bad to be so far to the
other extreme as to deplore everybody
else's indulgence would be equally bad
and it kind of shows a an attachment to
those sorts of those sorts of issues you
know you get the idea that many people
who are condemning other people for
engaging in sexual behavior probably
have some sort of deep abiding interest
in that very behavior otherwise they
wouldn't be so focused on it all the
time so he does say those things in the
end creating sexual desire can be very
very strong as a matter of fact he
brings us up a number of points
throughout the discourses it's so strong
that people actually use it as an excuse
when other excuses wouldn't fly they
they do wrongful things and then they
say well I'm in love or you know I could
help myself I was overcome by by lust
and he says something really quite quite
funny in book 4 chapter 1 he says you
know how people act and he says you got
to pay attention to yourself and you
need to make sure that if you're going
to be in stoic you actually live
according to those principles and he
says well like somebody stand over you
when you are in an excited condition and
saying philosopher you talk differently
in the school why are you deceiving us
why would you are a worm do you claim
that you are a man so he's talking in
general like about what oil gets spilled
and somebody gets all upset about it
they go to the restaurant and the dish
isn't prepared to their their liking and
some of me they're no longer the the
philosopher who's you know got
self-control and and you know can handle
things they get all worked up now what
he says it's really funny is this I
would like to stand over one of these
philosophers when he's engaged in sexual
intercourse so it is to see how he
exerts himself
what manner of words he utters whether
he remembers his own name or the
arguments that he hears or repeats or
reads so you know
Epictetus knows that when people are you
know aroused when they are sexually
excited when you know loss is like fully
engaged they kind of lose control over
their minds don't they you know they
they say all sorts of crazy stuff they
reveal things about themselves that
you've never have guessed you know when
we say wow I didn't know it was such a
freak that's an example look of that
sort of thing even the very act of sex
itself is in a certain way animalistic
you know people become just grunting
groaning routing kind of kind of things
and they don't seem to be in control so
epic you toises he's not saying don't
have sex he's just saying you know be
aware of what has
like probably many of us wouldn't want
to see pictures of ourselves or you know
videos of ourselves engaging in this
kind of behavior because we'd be like oh
my god I look like that oh that's
terrible
right so you know he's distressing in
that point just how strong sexual desire
can can be he also talks about sexual
desire as something which can make us
vulnerable to manipulation or coercion
by other people if we don't have our
lusts in check that may become something
like he says like a coin that can be
exchanged for other things so you want
to corrupt somebody if they're greedy
you bribe them right if they're an
adulterous kind of person if they're a
lawful kind of person you get them in
bed with somebody and now you've got
something over on them and you control
them so if you're the person who can't
keep your desires in check then you can
get yourself into all sorts of
predicaments and trouble and become you
know whatever kids would call the slave
of somebody else are sort of doubly
asleep right first your slave to the
lust to the object of designer because
you're willing to throw away things for
it and then you become the slave to the
person who actually has the goods on you
and can either procure your desire or
can show other people how shameful the
actions that you've been engaged in are
and just keep going and going and going
it's the opposite of freedom ironically
people think of it as you know freedom
means being able to have sex whenever
you want with whoever you want and
Epictetus would say mmmm maybe not quite
so much when it talks about adultery
like we said Daltry is kind of a limit
point of lust where must get so out of
hand that it transgresses social
conventions that are very important
those that are in some certain sense
rooted in in nature and then people get
into all sorts of debates about you know
evolutionary biology you know
speculation about whether we're supposed
to be monogamous
or not monogamous maybe women are but
men aren't and all that Epictetus would
say you know that's all fine and good
but there's also the social bond if I
have a wife and you're going to seduce
my wife I mean there's a problem too if
she allows herself to be seduced but
you're really transgressing not only
against her and me but also the rest of
society that's the way the ancient world
looked at it was a very problematic
thing
Gretchen also transgressing against
their families my wife's fine sect chief
you know Epictetus thinks that if you're
if you're married and you're pursuing
things outside of the marriage that
makes you a bad person and you want to
attend to that and get that under
control if you're seducing other
people's spouses now there you got a
double problem and so he talks about
adultery and he says that the adulteress
person is unjust they are they're doing
things that are wrong yeah you know no
they're not to be trusted
why not he talks about this in a chapter
about an adulterous guy who happens to
be a scholar first he says that look
you're ruining yourself in the process
you're destroying the person who is
trustworthy you're destroying the faith
or fidelity the Pistons in greed within
yourself you're making yourself a worse
person by doing them second you're also
destroying friendship phillium and
you're destroying society the Pulis not
are you destroying it absolutely no but
you are wrecking things to some degree
and if you think about how many
relationships not only between the two
people who get involved with each other
but all of the network of other people
have been ruined by infidelity sexual
infidelity you know it's pretty vast you
don't actually have to be married you
know he's thinking in terms of married
people but you don't necessarily need to
be married in order to have a great
friendship ruined by somebody cheating
on somebody else it can
RAK all sorts of organizations you know
when you've got people sleeping with
each other and then breaking up with
each other and that's sleeping with
other people within the workplace that's
one reason why workplace romances are
actually frowned upon you destroy the
social bond you make it more difficult
for thatthat society to function if you
know a neighborhood in which people are
cheating on each other it doesn't become
much of a neighborhood after a while
when everybody wants to beat each other
up or do mean things to each other /
each other's tires because they're so
angry about that sort of thing no they
also consider something that one of the
people who was involved with with
adultery could say and this is a an
issue that brings up a greater point
he's referring to this notion that you
find in for example Plato's Republic
talking about you know women being
common - you know each other
Plato doesn't actually endorse that
Plato is actually saying both both sets
of spouses are actually on an equal you
know relationship with each other and
you know who they're gonna sleep with is
actually assigned by the rulers but
other people took this this notion for a
minute what then you say are not women
by nature common property and that
produces sure let's go with that line of
reasoning and the little pig is the
common property the invited guests but
when portions have been assigned if it
so pleases you go ahead and approach a
snatch up the portion of the guest who
declines at your side steal it secretly
or slip your hand in and glut your greed
if you can tear around the piece of the
meat get your fingers greasy and lick
them you've made a great companion out
of feast nobodies don't want to sit with
you if you're attacked that way this is
the same way with with sexual partners
you know once we've actually decided
this person is in a relationship with
this person then it's hands off if you
want to respect the notion of there
being relationships and you want to be a
person of fidelity then you don't insist
on well anybody can sleep with anybody
at any time
as
sort of ideal he goes underneath and he
says you know when the lawgiver like a
hosted a banquet is a portion of the
parts are you not really like the rest
to look for your own portion instead of
filling away and glutton your greed upon
that which is another person's the other
thing to think about too that's involved
in this sort of mindset that Epictetus
doesn't get to but it is really worth
thinking about if we look at other
people in their sexual existence the
sexual dimensions of their being which
is really intrinsic to human being right
if we think of them primarily just as
sexual beings they're for our own
satisfaction of desires we are in a
certain sense lowering them we are not
treating them as truly fellow human
beings but just something to satisfy our
own desires and there's something
undignified and in a certain respect in
human about that that I think
epictetus himself doesn't quite you know
articulate but easily could have
articulated if you were to think about
it a little bit more and if you were
talked about it during that that lecture
so this gives you a good idea about it
Epictetus views on sexual desire itself
something that you gotta really pay
attention to and then channel into the
proper you know proper objects and in
particular about what happens when
things go really off the rails with
adultery